>>POLITID,NEW S ABE OF THE BITSG
COURSE, HAD PLENTYWENOO PEDDLEIS
S OF ELECTION
D CNN'Y  REPCA
CONGRESSMAN WHO WORKED FURIO
BEHIND THE SCEO
F AMERICANERITE-
CONGRESSMAO PUBLICLY
>> WE WAALLOTS AND
VORE COUNTED TO BE
CONGRESSMAN SCOT TRU'S
CONNECTED TRUMP WITH JEFFR
AN ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
D
AND PEELESS
ATTEMPTED A LEER COUP ATTHE JUSG
TO DOCUMENTS AND TMO
FORMERUSEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS.
PERRY HAD A FRIENDLYITH TRUMP.>
PERRY.T'S UNCL KNEEE MEN WERE
IN TH
ELECONON>> I DON'T UNDERSTIFALP
D, ACTIVITY,
WE DON THAT.
IN A BATCH OILS PEY
PASSESLO DOCUME
JUSTICE DERT
THAN VOTERS WHO VOTE
D NNCL
PERRY'S N LLH
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS AND
LAIN THE CALL TRUM
INSTRUS E OFFICIAL SAY TH CORRUD
LEAVE TRD THE
REPUBLICAN CESSMAN.RRHOUSE
FREEDOM CAUCUSN OF
PESYLVANIA'S ELECTIO
IN THE HOURS FOLLOWING THE
ON.
>> SADLY BUTUTELY I OBJECT
TO TLEMY
VEMMONWEALTH OF
AWARDING THE CONGRESSIONALTO OF
THE CAPITOL ONth
BACK IS SOUTH CENTRA
PENNSYLVANIA DF
ROLE TER ELECTION. >> ONE MANDUM
WHERE IS THAT L ORIMPROPER OR A
GETTING A START AT A LOCAL FARM
AT AGE 13 AND RI TR RANK
GENERALND
ICONGRE PERRY'SLESMAN
Y  W ELECTIONS.
F SUSPICION
S ION
HI
AGREE WOULOVERSAW
UNZ WE HAVE
LARGER OF WE WANT TO WIN  WE W
TO WIN ANY NECONSO DOUBLING  O
DIVEA POTENTIAL
DEATH SENTENCE FOR THE
REPUBLIC Pep
PERRY ABOUT  TO WHERTHISWEEKN
OF HIST OFFICES.
KNEAO  S IF AT FOR
ANY
RELEASE TH JO.IS ACTIONS HAVE .S
WE KNOW WHERHE STANDS SO MUCH F
THAT.
LES DISCUSS.
IN KICK IT
WITH YOU ON THEL
BEHIND-T-SS SHENANIGANS
WITH OFFICIALS THEE TH
SMACKS OF A COUP ATTEMPTO YOU MH
WM UNWILLINGNESS TSWER FOR HISC.
S TO YOUR POIN
E AMERICM CONGRESSMAN SCOTRRY I
RELYEN
ASARRRAYNTED OUT IN
TRYING TO PROMOTE THE BIG
EACH ENCOURAGINGE STEATS HIS HO
PEE OF THE KEY RUSTBELT SWUNG O
INTRODUCSARA BE FORMRE RELATIVE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHO
BECAMIN PUSH THE -- S
E ELECTION
EE
PEOPHEDELI TO
HE ELEN,US
CABINET OFFICIALS WHO,
COURSEBUM BUT MEERS OF CONGRESS
DEPART
S WHR
COMMITTEES WERG
THESE MATTERS FORWARD ANES FOR .
I MEANIT'S REMARE A
E TUALLY HPI
>> RIGHT, ANITT
ONLYERE SO-CALLED LIE BUT Y HADE
IT LIKE THE IT'SBU SAYING,
EFORE WE SHOULNOCEY JOE ELECTOL
ELECTIONS REAND, WS BECO MAKE
AGAIN, TO YOUR POINT, IT DOES
EA THEIR BASE IN
MAGA REPUBLICANS AREING WHRS ARE
TOERCAUS
MIDDLE AND DEMOCRATS A NOT
PAUL WHO BY THE Y  VERO HAS ALSE
TE T S RAISEDTHAT HIS WIFE PURC
AT THE
WEIT WASN'A  INVESTMENT.IS A PED
W
IT DAYLAD  KD DECIDE IF TH'S PRM
LL THAT MASKS DON'T
WORK.
YOU KNOW, BOE S VESTMENT. SHE D
BENEFI TTH
IT'S TO GO FORWARD AND TELL SK
WHE Y DO.NG AND MOANING
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOUTUBE FOR
WHOLE WEEKEIR ACCOUNT,HO WEEK.
MISS THE BS CONCERAND BE GROUND.
PEAUTH
IN HIS KHALF A MILLIONND ALMOS0E
DIED.
HE HAS AN OBLIGATION IT TELL THE
HIS STOCK TRANSACTION
HEALTH.
A LOT MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
UR THAT.
>> IT WAS A BIDEAL BECAUWAS SUSP
RIST THOUGH.>> IT'S A SLAP ON T
EXHES
DA
ALNAIN CITH HAVE BEEN
DEMOCRATIC STRONDS, NOT WHAT DAL
HAVE YOU SEEN ATGIVING
MENE TWHENS AN EXPECTATION THA
A LOT O
NEWS FOR REPUBLICA
EARLY ESTIMATE
TEXAS, FDA, THEY ARE PICKING
UP THE CONGRESSIONAL SEATS BUT
CHALLENGESING FOR REPUICANS OR E
OF THESE STATES ARP
RI ARE REPN
NOW, THERE'S O OVE
A HALF
ARE DEMOGRAPHI?
WE SE CENSUSHUGE
GROWTH IN TERMS OF THE NON-WHIT
WHICH HAS HU POLIMPLICATIONS BU
LAULIO FLODA
IS GROWING DY
ME IS BECOMING ALUER
STE.LOOK FOR INSTAE A E
OS YA COUNTY WHERE I GRE
UP, YOU'VE HAD HUG
GROWTH THERE, E LATINO
COTY AND A SWUNG A RED THI
DEMOGRAPHICS AREN'T DESTINY BUT
THE'R DEMOCRATY  TOWARDS REDIST
>> SHOULBE WORRITH IT UNCOTHEIR
THAT APP BEYONE OR
RS.
REACH PENECEILE E  GOING
MA HAVE TO APPE OPOLITAN A A GRS
AGO IS NOW.G WITH THEEET G PA
TAT
AD AND CITIE THINK IS WHAT OUR
FORMERSI
I K THE
I LIVE IN RURAAM
ONE OF MNSHIHOUNTRY MUSIC. COUNI